all right you
ready hey Keith metro police come over here hey
metro police come over here all right thanks buddy
come on over here appreciate your cooperation
okay going stand right here in front of the
car yep yep we going and put it down I know hang
on put put that down for a second all right got
hooks you have anything on you sir
no okay yeah we'll get you a drink
hang on right just want to make sure
you got no weapons on you or anything
okay separate the thank
you put your palms together
like you're clapping I just
want to make sure These Cuffs
can to be all right on you yep
uh
good you have anything on you sir phone and water
phone and water perfect we're going to put you in
the car I need I I need to drink some water drink
you just going for a walk or what yeah okay you
do like a morning walk every day or okay we'll
get you some water my man got to get it now as
soon as we get you in the car we'll get we'll
get you in yeah one put in the car all right
appreciate it sir all right let's walk over here
sir okay don't worry your water's going to come
double walking all that yep that's good
you got legs I don't hold on before
yep we got to put some leg Shackles on you it's
just part of our policy are you wearing double
pants sir you wearing double pants or these are
boxes all right I'm G pull these all the way
up where go I'm down real
quick cool all right so going and have a
seat right in here I'm going to help you
out yep just kind of put your butt up
against there kick that foot up ready
I'm a pro dude I got it you got it all
right he I'm a pro he said I'm a pro all
right no we're
done I can do it my front is clear I'm right
here okay
you have anything on you sir no all you had
was phone and uh water phone and water we're
going to put you in the car I need I need
I need a drink if you want man I'm thirsty
get a drink my man you just going for a walk or
what yeah okay you do like a morning walk every
day or okay we get you some water my man get now
yeah soon as we get you in the car we'll get you
we'll get all right appreciate it sir let walk
over here sir okay going wor your water's and
com you got legs I don't anybody have legs
yeah I got some yep hold on before we put them
inep we got to put some leg Shack
on it's just part of our policy are
you wearing double pants sir
you wearing double pants the
Box
right have
right
there got Pro you I'm a
pro anything else out here no we're done custody
camera
y more that water
yep all right go swing your feet
out right over
here all right we're going to Walk This Way
just biger steps I'll get you out of those in a
second all right going to have
you face the car real quick you
go yep separate your feet for
me lean up against the car for
me
going to keep your phone up here
with me so it doesn't bounce
around all right sir go aad and have
a seat you need help or you got it all
right all right now you can sit as sideway if
that helps too I know those things aren't the
most comfortable things ain't the fuzzy ones
so I don't know I'll be that in a sec yeah
well all right you got his paperwork or he
already knows Lieutenant Paige got it yep no
problem so what they got you for
man biggest case in egas
history oh yeah yeah like recent
September 7th
1996 oh no wow that's a long time that's
a long time away you know what I'm talking
about H you know what I'm talking about yeah
not a detective quite yet but yeah it's a long
time away man what was that 20 something years
no more than that yeah should took him a while
huh I
worried well I mean that's what Court's for
right oh so they uh raid your house and stuff
huh that was like mons ago yeah walk
around the corner just want walk my
walk
wow they didn't make a scene like last
time oh they did oh they three squat I'm in
my I hear a bunch of walkie-talkies in
the house behind me saw people over the
C me and theat dude peeped over
the gate at the same time in the
house my whole house this is
Vegas Metropolitan and we're
very subtle then huh do that I was
walking down the street dude jumped
out apprehension team or something